alain delon revenons à votre carrière
vous avez vous avez des regrets si vous
estimez con pour l'instant ne vous a pas
servi les rôles auxquels vous vous avez
rêvé ou non non non non j'ai aucun
regret j'ai eu la chance si vous voulez
de un très très grand privilège et la
chance de faire de ne jamais devoir
faire un film pour vivre pour manger
j'ai toujours choisi depuis 20 ans je
suis producteur j'ai toujours choisi en
général mais sujet les gens avec qui je
voulais travailler les metteurs en scène
souvent donc je ne je ne regrette
absolument rien j'ai fait vraiment tout
ce que j'ai voulu faire comme j'ai
souhaité le faire
à segré beaucouzé beaucoup d'eux un très
très long collège
c'est un phénomène aussi de
l'indépendance de la liberté d'action
voilà c'est surtout ça qui est important
c'est le l'indépendance que vous avez
voulu marquer par rapport à votre métier
parce qu'il ya certains metteurs en
scène avec qui vous n'avez jamais
tournée qui pourtant sont des grands
noms oui on ne comprend pas pourquoi
l'association delon truffaut delon
sautet ne s'est jamais fait une question
d'honneur d'unités retourner le couteau
dans la plaie parce qu'il ya très
longtemps que j'ai envie de travailler
avec claude sautet ça ne s'est jamais
présenté truffaut malheureusement il a
disparu vous le savez donc ce n'est plus
possible
je sais que je peux
truffaut avait une la manifester donc il
me l'a dit une certaine admiration pour
ma carrière
et moi je lui rendais bien d'ailleurs et
quant à claude sautet vous savez claude
sautet terrain auteur d'abord c'est un
écrivain c'est lui qui choisit ses
sujets qui en prépare les scénarios qui
les travaillent qui les adaptent il
travaille très peu il fait un film en
général tous les trois quatre cinq ans
et puis bah ça ne s'est jamais produit
la rencontre ne s'est jamais fait une
fois il m'a proposé un film je les
refuse et je ne sais pas s'il en a été
plus ou moins affectés
c'était max et les ferrailleurs et
depuis on ne sommes jamais rencontrés je
crois que à un autre téléphone